في محاوله لقطع يد التكنولوجيا الصينيه
المتغلله في الاجواء الامريكيه او على
الاقل تكبيلها وابقائها تحت النظر رحب
البيت الابيض باقتراح قانون من شانه ان
يمكن الولايات المتحده من حظر تطبيق تيك
توك للفيديوهات القصيره المملوك لشركه
صينيه حيث اكد مستشار الامن القومي جيك
سوليفان اهميه مشروع القانون الهاتف لمنع
حكومات اجنبيه من استغلال خدمات تكنولوجيه
ودرء المخاطر الامنيه المرافقه المتحدثه
باسم تيك توك وصفت من جهتها اي حظ اي حظر
امريكي بالحظر على تصدير الثقافه والقيم
الامريكيه الى اكثر من مليار شخص يستخدمون
التطبيق حول العالم لكن الرد المباشر اتمن
تيك توك كما وصف وجاء في خانه المنافسه
الشديده لاحدى الخدمات الامريكيه الرائده
بمجال الفيديوهات وهي يوتيوب
حيث اضافت ميزه جديده
وهي ميضه ميزات سيريز تتمثل باتاحه نشر
فيديوهات اطول تصل مدتها الى 20 دقيقه
بعدما كانت محدوده بعشر دقائق فقط متيحا
ومتيحه هنا لصناع المحتوى مجالا جديدا
لكسب المال